Nearly two billion people are living without reliable access to power.
When the sun goes down, that's the end of your day.
You're not reading any books.
You're not doing any math problems.
If you think about how many hours a child loses, over the span of a year,...
...and you compare that to the rest of the kids in the world who do have access to power,...
...you start to see how you can be left back on that path...
...towards creating the world that you want.
This is a Soccket.
It looks like a soccer ball, plays a lot like a soccer ball,...
...but it's actually a lot more.
It's an airless ball that generates electricity when you play with it.
Inside the Soccket, there's a pendulum, a generator motor,...
...and a lithium ion rechargeable battery.
When the ball rolls, the pendulum turns the generator that then powers up the battery.
After 30 minutes of play, you can get over three hours of clean, renewable light.
So the idea here is we're providing a platform for play...
...to make the journey towards the solution that much happier.